[Música]
Haití está sumido en una catástrofe
humanitaria con varios frentes violencia
de las pandillas inflación y un brote de
cólera además casi 5 millones de
personas sufren inseguridad alimentaria
en el país según el programa mundial de
alimentos de Naciones Unidas tenemos
análisis en esta edición en Reino Unido
tras menos de dos meses de gobierno la
primera ministra listas destituyó a
suministro de finanzas cuasi cuarten
responsable del plan de reforma fiscal
que llevó al desplome de la libra
esterlina en medio de las presiones de
su propio partido tras rectificó su plan
y nombró a Jeremy Hunt en la cartera
Tenemos reporte desde Londres
Vladimir Putin advirtió que un choque de
Rusia con la otan causaría una
catástrofe global el presidente ruso
aseguró que no son necesarios más
ataques a gran escala contra Ucrania sin
embargo este viernes las fuerzas de
Moscú volvieron a bombardear las
ciudades a por ella
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Haití porque
según el más reciente informe del
programa mundial de alimentos de
Naciones Unidas el país se enfrenta a
una catástrofe humanitaria debido a la
violencia en sus calles que ha
ocasionado que cientos de personas
sufran de escasez de alimentos y de agua
potable además un nuevo brote de cólera
pone en riesgo a la población ahora para
analizar la situación del país Contamos
con Nora Restrepo portavoz precisamente
del programa mundial de alimentos de la
ONU no era Buenas tardes empecemos por
Cuáles son las conclusiones principales
de su informe
Buenas tardes la situación en Haití
lastimosamente se ha deteriorado en los
últimos años hasta llegar al punto en el
que estamos hoy donde la situación es
realmente catastrófica estamos hablando
de que cerca de la mitad de la población
haitiana o sea 4.7 millones de personas
están en inseguridad alimentaria ya sea
crisis emergencia o por primera vez en
la historia de Haití catastrófica
entonces hablamos de un millón 800 mil
personas ya en estado de emergencia de
hambre y unas 20.000 personas en la zona
metropolitana de sipeso ley que están Ya
en un nivel el más alto de la escala de
catástrofe
Y qué salidas habría esta crisis
multifacética en que como dicen en su
informe todo está conectado no la crisis
de suministros con la de seguridad o la
de salud
efectivamente el pueblo haitiano está
viviendo múltiples crisis desde todos
los ángulos incluyendo también en el sur
en zonas agrícolas
donde se ha visto muy poca lluvia y
pérdida de cosechas recordemos que el
año pasado un terremoto que afectó a
mucha población también del sur todavía
se está recuperando entonces debemos
realmente trabajar por un lado en la
asistencia monetaria de emergencia y por
otro lado dar respuesta a lo que es el
desarrollo a largo plazo debemos
trabajar juntos es un desafío enorme y
país está en un momento tumultuoso
realmente tenemos que enfocarnos todos
en el pueblo más pobre más vulnerable de
Haití en estos momentos y precisamente
usted hacía referencia a esta asistencia
de emergencia y respecto a esto el
Primer Ministro Ariel Enric pidió que la
comunidad internacional mandara tropas
al país para restablecer la seguridad en
una petición apoyada por otro lado por
el voluntario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez ustedes lo ven como una
solución
la crisis política realmente es un
factor importante en lo que está
viviendo Haití hoy pero no es el único
la inseguridad ha aumentado
increíblemente más los otros problemas
que hemos mencionado nosotros como
agencia humanitaria trabajamos de manera
independiente
sin contar con los temas políticos Por
supuesto que queremos una resolución
pacífica y rápida por el pueblo haitiano
que hoy está viviendo una catástrofe
no la Restrepo portavoz del programa
mundial de alimentos de Naciones Unidas
Muchas gracias por su tiempo y por su
análisis
cambiamos hora de información vamos a
Europa porque en Reino Unido tras menos
de dos meses de gobierno siguiendo la
renuncia de Boris Johnson recordemos la
primera ministras destituyó a suministro
de finanzas cuasi él era el responsable
del plan de reforma fiscal que proponía
el mayor recorte de impuestos de los
últimos 50 años la previsión de una
caída en la recaudación provocó la
pérdida de confianza de los mercados
como consecuencia el gobierno de ristras
se vio forzado a dar marcha atrás en el
plan económico que había prometido por
ejemplo la líder del gobierno británico
mantendrá la subida de impuestos de
sociedades un alza prevista por el
ejecutivo de Johnson y que ella se había
comprometido anular el nuevo encargado
de las finanzas británicas Jeremy Hunt
presentará la nueva reforma fiscal el 31
de octubre ahora los detalles con
nuestra corresponsal en Londres Luisa
Pulido
la salida del ministro de finanzas cuasi
cuartel era predecible tras semanas y
semanas de crisis en la ya golpeada
economía británica la caída histórica en
la libra esterlina y la incertidumbre en
los mercados cuasi cuartel estuvo en el
gobierno 38 días de los cuales la
mayoría estuvo ocupado en tratar de
apagar los incendios causados por el
mini presupuesto o el plan financiero
diseñado por el gobierno para recuperar
la economía listas tuvo hoy que
sacrificar a uno de sus grandes y más
cercanos aliados políticos para salvar
su gobierno sin embargo hemos escuchado
recientemente voces que publica y
Privada y privadamente están pidiendo
que la salida del issstras sea lo más
rápido posible un hecho sin precedentes
tratando de calmar el partido la primera
ministra ha designado a Jeremy Hunt como
el nuevo ministro de finanzas un
veterano cargos del gobierno quedará
seguramente más tranquilidad a los
mercados la primera ministra ha
anunciado en rueda de prensa también que
removerá asuntos polémicos de este plan
financiero sin embargo no hay certeza de
que estas movidas sean suficientes para
calmar los ánimos del partido
conservador
y continuamos con más información
económica de Europa en Francia casi un
30% de las gasolineras presentan
problemas de suministro una escasez
provocada por las huelgas en las
petroleras Epson Mobile y total energes
nuestra periodista en París Erika
olavarría con los detalles de la
situación
la huelga en las refinería francesas
continúa después de que anoche el
sindicato más a la izquierda cgt se
retirará de una reunión de la directiva
de total junto a los trabajadores porque
se opone a una propuesta salarial que
les hizo la empresa esta consiste en un
reajuste de un 7% de los salarios más
una prima de entre 3.000 y 6000 euros
Hay que decir que esa propuesta fue
apoyada por el sindicato más moderado
cfdt y otros menores Que en total suman
más que el 50% de los trabajadores sin
embargo hay que recordar que en
depósitos y en refinerías el sindicato
mayoritario es la cgt justamente ellos
estaban pidiendo un reajuste del 10% 7%
corresponde a la inflación y 3% a las
grandes ganancias que han obtenido las
petroleras en vista del alto precio de
los combustibles y de la energía por lo
mismo un tercio de las gasolineras
continúa en Francia con problemas de
abastecimiento según las autoridades eso
debiera normalizarse en las próximas
horas en vista de la ya en dos depósitos
donde los trabajadores han sido
obligados a laborar justamente la cgt
tuvo hoy una mala noticia a ese respecto
el tribunal de Rubén rechazó un recurso
que había presentado este sindicato
considerando que era ilegal esta
intervención que hacía el estado porque
atentaba contra el derecho a huelga
además a la cgt tiene otro plan y es que
para el próximo martes está convocando
una huelga interprofesional de varios
sectores ya se han sumado los
trabajadores de la energía de los
transportes de los servicios y de la
Administración pública
en rueda de prensa tras el encuentro de
líderes de la comunidad de Estados
independientes el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin hizo varias declaraciones
en relación con la invasión de Ucrania
por un lado señaló que la movilización
de reservistas está pronta a completarse
por otro lado Consideró que no ve
necesarios nuevos ataques a gran escala
contra Ucrania sin embargo hoy las
fuerzas de Moscú volvieron a bombardear
la ciudad de Sa polilla Putin también
señaló que un enfrentamiento entre Rusia
y la otan provocaría una catástrofe
Global
en cualquier caso llevar a las tropas de
la otana un choque directo con las
tropas rusas sería algo muy peligroso
que podría llevar a una catástrofe
global Espero que aquellos que están
hablando de esto tengan suficiente
sentido común como para no llegar a
tomar cualquier paso peligroso
y como decíamos por otro lado putina
declarado que no son necesarios más
ataques a gran escala contra Ucrania
como los que lanzó este lunes el
ejército ruso sobre todo el territorio
ucraniano como respuesta a la explosión
en el puente de crimea un incidente que
el kremlin calificó de acto de
terrorismo ucraniano en suelo ruso sin
embargo como decíamos hoy las fuerzas de
Moscú han vuelto a bombardear la ciudad
categoría Putin también anunció que el
proceso de movilización de reservistas
terminará pronto
[Música]
el trabajo de movilización está llegando
a su fin justo ahora tenemos 220.000
personas movilizadas de las 300.000
anunciadas creo que en las próximas dos
semanas la movilización se habrá
complicado
y por otro lado ante los avances de la
contraofensiva ucraniana en el este del
país las autoridades prorusas de la
región de gerson hanneccionada
ilegalmente por el kremlin piden a los
residentes que evacúen hacia el
territorio ruso reconocido
internacionalmente lo que kiev denuncia
como una deportación de sus ciudadanos
apenas dos semanas después de que Moscú
reclamara ilegalmente la anexión de
gerson las evacuaciones ya han comenzado
las autoridades rusas citaron el jueves
a los ciudadanos de la estratégica
región a huir hacia el sur de Ucrania
mientras que sigue Rompiendo las líneas
del frente
tras el discurso del jefe de la región
ucraniana de gersombra de mirzaldón el
gobierno ruso ha tomado la decisión de
organizar la asistencia a las personas
que abandonan la región hacia otras
regiones del país proporcionaremos a
todos alojamiento gratuito y todo lo
necesario a los que deciden quedarse
permanentemente en su nuevo lugar se les
proporcionará un hogar
se ha informado de la primera llegada de
evacuaciones a la región rusa de rostov
mientras que otros se han dirigido a la
Península de crimea a pesar de Los
Fuertes bombardeos de Moscú como aquí en
la cercana ciudad de niko Life otras
cinco localidades de gerson han sido
retomadas por las fuerzas ucranianas y
el aluvión de ataques rusos en todo el
país No parece haber mermado la moral de
las tropas uc
y de equipajeros el hecho de que dejaran
los proyectiles y esparcieran solo parte
de la pólvora demuestra que huyeron muy
rápido
si nos movemos rápidamente habrá muchas
pérdidas no tenemos que apresurarnos
pero tenemos que aplastarlos hasta el
final
Mientras tanto en Moscú se está llevando
a cabo un esfuerzo propagandístico para
apuntalar el apoyo en casa aquí en
saporilla se ha filmado a combatientes
por los rusos bien equipados
preparándose para el combate pero hasta
que los tiempos de miles de reservistas
movilizados por Moscú se han operativos
kiev tratará de mantener el ímpetu de su
contra ofensiva en el frente Sur
gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros
[Música]